This is you, this is your genealogy
And this is your family tree explanation.
You have parents, and your parents have parents.
They are your grandparents,
Of course they also have parents - your great grandparents.
Keep going up, always add a "Zeng" word
Every "祖" word
There will be a generation between you and the "ancestors"
grandparents? a "ancestor",
a generation between you
Have you ever had grandparents?
Three Zeng Yizu, four generations
Back to the beginning, you have brothers and sisters,
And your parents also have it. they are
Your uncle and aunt.
Going up, you might call these people your "zu" and "zu".
But your grandparents’ brothers and sisters
It is actually your uncle and uncle.
I used to be in the upper part of my grandparents.
The brothers and sisters of your great-grandparents were
Zeng Shuzu and his uncle.
Below the genealogy, the children of your brothers and sisters
Is your nephew and niece
Then you are their uncle / aunt or aunt / aunt.
Their children are your grandsons
Then you are their uncle or uncle.
Looked up and down, now
I have to look to the side.
When you get married, there will be everyone's favorite.
in law. You are with your husband or wife.
Brothers and sisters are at the same level.
You think you are just like them. Whole new family
The relationship to you is the same as their relationship with your spouse.
There is only a "in-law" suffix.
Everything looks straightforward
Only your spouse’s brothers and sisters are your brothers and sisters.
But your brothers and sisters are also your brothers and sisters?
This is a bit fuzzy
Ok, the in-laws say enough, continue to talk about you should
See the reason for this video. Cousins ​​and sisters?
They are the children of your sister/uncle and aunt/aunt,
But there are many types of cousins.
To understand them better,
To simplify this genealogy, think about the next generation.
Here are you, your children, and your grandson.
Your grandchildren are cousins ​​and sisters to each other.
Their children, your great grandchildren, are the second cousins ​​of each other.
This relationship has continued
Cousins, sisters, and ancestors
He tells you how many cousins ​​are on the family tree.
Fourth cousin? Middle four generations
And have the same great-grandfather
From the first law,
Your first cousin has the same grandparent with you.
The second generation of the same great-grandparent
Just connect the number of cousins ​​and the number of "z"
Then everything is done, how simple
Off topic: turn this rule in turn
Brothers and sisters can call each other's 0th cousin
And they should do this
Are you your -1 cousins? What ghost?
End of topic
Ok, nothing to say.
Oh, there is still a little
You may have noticed that these cousins ​​are on a generation basis.
What is omitted is the generation of their upper heads.
For example, what relationship do these two people have?
Starting from a younger generation
The first cousin, calculate the separate generation
This is a cousin divided twice, three times apart
This is the second cousin to separate twice, once apart
On this simplified picture
It’s too simple, but most genealogy
It looks more like this.
In fact, the rules are the same.
Just want to call faster, who is more difficult
For example, your second cousin is separated twice or your great-grandfather
Here is a picture you can download,
Will help you figure out
Who is who?
In your next family collection and of course
Show how much you hang
Then we are really finished. Unless you start
I want the value of such a big family.
How many of you have had great grandparents?
sixty-four?
These former grandparents gave you a bunch of cousins
This form totals to the tenth cousin
Or do you have more than 2,000?
This is too much, but
This figure has a big asterisk.
Let's talk about it next time,
In 'family inheritance; second volume'.